i really want to start with sincere
congratulations and i really i have to
ask you the first question because
how mad was everyone because everyone
else had to train like a [ __ ]
and go through the ringer and eat and
like do everything and you're just
sitting there like i'm the king i know i
know i remember when we uh we had to get
together viola's place in south africa
we went down to a place and i went to a
kitchen i opened the fridge i was like
yo
where did you sat like gabby came in
like
okay nah i had to respect it because the
devotion that they put into it for us
coming in who didn't necessarily have to
have that commitment um we we were
inspired and and the passion of the
movie was was transferred into us when
we just saw lashana come on set and her
back is looking ripped on some hulk
stuff and then you see you see sheila
practicing and she's swinging the spear
you know across her body and with ease i
was thinking to myself there's been a
good few months that i did not see
this is crazy but it was it was really
inspirational to witness yeah i i really
want to commend you guys on the action
set pieces and and what you did in the
movie and i i don't think people at home
really realize what it takes to do
something like this where you're
actually on frame and it's not like
cutting away to like the back of your
head and the stunt double you know what
i mean
it's i think an hour away
of that fact that it's not going to be a
cut away you know slice here and take a
shot there and that it really had to be
a
360 performance um
you know just upped the level of
commitment that we had to have like it
wasn't just okay i swing this here and i
hit that there it was the level of
detail that we had to really feed into
our performances i just
that's why you know john would see me by
a trailer practicing you know in a lunch
break or you know even after shooting
hours because we just we just so wanted
to be able to
live up to the challenge that gina had
set which was you know let's do your own
stunts it makes it you know a joy for
them to edit as well when it comes to
the post-production suite because they
can just get super creative knowing that
it's us you know and they can really
showcase it and you can really feel it
as well you don't you don't as an
audience member you don't feel the the
tricks and the smoke and mirrors you
feel like you're there i think it's more
transportive
um
so yeah it was it was it was a lot but i
think we were really excited to do it as
well as a challenge but we were really
up for trying to meet it yeah and when
you have someone who just sees that in
you i mean how dare you look upon it and
say oh gosh i'm not going to do my own
stunts i'm not going to raise the bar
for this incredible film that's going to
take place when everyone's done so much
work to even get it off the ground um we
have to respect it and we brought about
a process that meant we were able to
meet um the women we were representing
in the center of the space we were able
to raise our bar higher um so that we
could
show the world that their bar was high
and this is what we come from we come
from a long line of like high bars um
and it feels it felt really good to um
to be able to
use your body in a way that informed how
you characterize these people you know
so that i could know that the core of
azogi is actually real you know she
she's speaking from a different place i
was physically speaking from a different
place everyone sounded and felt
different energetically when i would
stand next to sheila in a scene i'm like
this is not sheila right now because of
the training her body is moving
differently um and i and i
really
i really enjoyed watching how
stealth-like we were and how
how they really took care of that in the
edit actually um in how hard we worked
and i think it's something to be really
proud of because we may not ever get an
opportunity like this again to go 100 in
you know and have someone trust you that
much to be able to do it yourself so i'm
really grateful on that note i already
got to stop i'm just going to say
congratulations i really hope it's a
huge hit for you guys thank you nice to
see everybody